[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday
children are going back to school from
tomorrow all pupils in
england can return to their classrooms
it will be staggered in some places
and it won't feel like normal but many
parents and children will still be
breathing a big sigh of relief that
homeschooling is over
it's also clear though that the
consequences of months stuck at home
will impact
this generation of young people for
years to come and from a political point
of view getting children back in the
classroom is just the beginning
it's also about catching up on lost
learning and making sure
exams are fair well today we've got the
perfect lineup to talk about schools
going back the education secretary gavin
williamson will be joining us in just a
moment
and we'll also be hearing from the chief
inspector of schools in england amanda
spillman
labour's shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy will be on the show
and ahead of international women's day
i've spoken to the executive director of
un women
fumezile malambo and gooka and after
nicola sturgeon gave evidence to the
salmon inquiry we'll also be talking to
the snp's
mari black firstly ahead of all children
in england returning to school tomorrow
we can speak now to the education
secretary gavin williamson thank you so
much for being with us
on the program mr williamson um keen of
course to talk about the return
of pupils to the classrooms but i just
want to start on nhs
pay if i may and the government deciding
to give nurses a pay rise of just one
percent
what is it about the last year that's
made the government feel that nurses
deserve a pay cut in real terms well the
government's
every stage being clear in terms of our
commitment to the nhs this is why
over the last year we've seen an extra
six billion pounds being invested into
the nhs this is why over the next few
years
we're going to be seeing a increase of
close to 34 billion pounds going into
the nhs
and over a million nhs staff they're
going to be
receiving uh pay increases over and
above that
but also um we are facing
difficult economic challenges we're
facing uh
almost three-quarters of a million
people who are unemployed and
we have in the context of that decided
to exempt
the nhs from the public sector pay
freeze which is
the only part of the public sector that
has been exempted from that
at the same time though nurses are
getting a pay rise of 1 i mean inflation
next year is expected to be 1.5
so that works out as a pay cut in real
terms i can't help thinking this has got
a flavor of marcus rashford about it you
know
everyone can see the u-10 coming are you
just being wheeled out to defend a
policy that the government's going to
roll back on
well over the last few years we've seen
record increases
in terms of the pay going to our nurses
and our doctors quite rightly
we are facing them uh we're we're
effectively facing a
much more difficult economic time and
economic period we've seen a
shrinking of our economy of 10 uh but
what
uh this is is part of a process and
we've
put this forward uh to uh for
for for nurses and for the nhs and uh
but we are always investing in our nhs
this is why we've had a record
investment this year
and continued record investment in our
national health service over the coming
years
the royal college of nursing is
considering industrial action
would that be responsible well what we
always want to do is work with
all of our partners within the nhs to be
able to
get to the very best possible place
we've seen the nhs do magnificent work
over
the last year we've seen a massive
investment in terms of our nhs
but also in terms of tackling covid
industrial action specifically would
industrial action
be responsible well no one wants to see
industrial
action i'm certain the royal college of
nursing wouldn't want to see industrial
action
but the government is completely
committed to that investment in the nhs
you've seen that all the way through the
pandemic but you've seen that over the
past 10 years
where you've seen record increases in
the amount of investment and the amount
of money that we've been putting into
the nhs
and that isn't just going to be
continuing over this year but it's going
to be continuing over
uh subsequent years as well okay
at a time when you know you're talking
about the economic challenges is it a
good look when
nurses are facing a pay restraint for
example
that the prime minister is considering
splashing out some money refurbishing
the downing street flat
well what we all recognize is you know
it's a
period of uh real making sure that we
have sort of restrained right across the
uh for public sector but we aren't
nervous about in terms of investing in
those key public services such as the
nhs
such as schools and investing industrial
paper as well then
but uh you know i i i'm i'm like you uh
something probably more interested more
fascinated about making sure children
get back to school tomorrow
and uh i know from my perspective as a
as a dad that's certainly what i'm
wanting to say and i'm sure what many of
your viewers are wanting to see as well
okay well let's move on to school shall
we do teachers deserve a pay rise
well we've already we saw this this year
the largest pay increase for
teachers since 2005 but there is going
to be pay restraint uh there is going to
be a pay freeze for the coming year
uh but we are continuing to invest in
schools we're continuing to invest in
um you know schools right across the
country making sure some of the lowest
funded schools
get extra increases and this gives
schools for resources
in order to be able to support children
as a return back to school but
uh you know we are facing you know
a tough economic time that's why this
year there will be a
coming year there will be a pay freeze
but for this
year that we're entering into of course
it's teachers think the largest increase
since 2005.
okay now of course as you mentioned
school's going back uh tomorrow or
people return to the classrooms and
tomorrow
big day for so many pupils and parents
across the country
and in secondary schools pupils and
staff will be asked to wear face masks
how is this going to be enforced well
what we saw
in september we asked all children to be
wearing face masks in communal areas
where there are national restrictions
which
increasingly uh covered and ended up
covering the whole of the country
and what we saw during that period
there's an incredibly
large number of pupils that followed the
rules uh they were supported and
following the rules by
uh teachers and members of staff and it
worked very very well
and i think uh pupils recognize the
importance of
doing whatever they can do not just to
protect themselves but to protect their
friends and the whole school community
as well as their families and the wider
community
at the same time it's quite different
though isn't it asking children to wear
face masks all day in the classroom
rather than just in communal areas
and it sounds from your answer that
there's not really anything that you're
doing other than asking pupils
to do it in primary schools as well and
teachers are just supposed to wear masks
where possible i'm really not sure what
that even means i mean it sounds a
little bit like you're saying this is
too difficult for us to work out
we're just going to leave it to the
teachers you just sort out yourselves
not at all what we're doing is we set up
very clear guidance as to how teachers
are best be able to approach this
and it's actually informed by public
health england
and their best advice as to how best to
approach this and reduce transmission
but wearing a face mask is just one
small element
of all the uh all the protections that
we put in place
you know it's whether it is you know the
distancing whether it's
bubbling whether it's keeping uh year
groups together and smaller groups
together whether it's for staggered
uh you know uh sort of home times and
sort of uh welcoming to school
times all of these measures go towards
reducing covert and what we saw between
september and christmas
is incredibly successful in reducing the
number of instances in covid in schools
only 0.2 percent of pupils
had confirmed covid during that time so
it goes to show it works
but we're adding these extra layers of
protection not just for masks but also
the testing
really to be able to support schools and
help them but it's not just
one single thing it's many many things
that schools are doing
to be able to protect pupils and protect
staff
of course another way that you could
reduce cover transmission schools would
be through vaccinations and would you
like to see
people under the age of 18 be eligible
for vaccinations
well this has got to be absolutely
informed by this best scientific and
medical advice and
as you're aware there currently isn't a
vaccine that's available
for those who are under 16 and only one
available for those under 18. so we've
really got to see the research of the
trials and we've got to
look to the best medical and scientific
advice that will be provided by the jcpi
who are the
independent experts who are advising
government on this
uh but when we look at vaccinations i
mean the fact that we're
uh you know rolling this out so
incredibly rapidly the fact that the
number of doses are going to be
available to
the nhs is going to be increasing from
two million to four million a week
really goes to show the transformative
progress that we're making and the fact
that this
is what is going to help us unlock uh
the whole of a country
and you know we look to next week um
and i think the whole nation looks next
week with some real excitement
because we're looking towards next week
and it's our first the nation's first
step
out of lockdown the first step towards
this uh
process of recovery and getting everyone
back to
the lives that we had uh just over a
year ago
you say there's going to be a process of
recovery and there clearly will have to
be
you know pretty substantial process of
recovery to help
children and particularly disadvantaged
children
recover from a year of disrupted
education and you've got a review going
on into seeing how best and pupils can
catch up
um one of the things that you've said
it's right to have a discussion about
is shortening that summer holiday
and potentially moving to a five-term
year is that something that you're
seriously considering
well it's a whole range of different
sort of proposals that we're looking at
whether it's a five-term year whether
it's lengthening the school day
but also measures such as enhancing the
support that we give to teachers
uh supporting them in their professional
development making sure
they can be actually the very best of
themselves um it's
looking at different specifically though
specifically on the holidays
is that something that is seriously on
the table it could happen
uh were we looking at holidays we're
looking at lengthening the school day
we're looking at a whole range of
measures and we've asked uh sir kevin
collins
to leave nose stone unturned for us we
see this as one of those
moments a little bit like the 1944
education reform act that came out of
the second world war
um about how we can be transformative in
terms of
changing and improving the opportunities
for young people
but it's got to be evidence-based we've
got to look as to what is going to have
the biggest
positive impact on children's lives
that's the approach that we're taking
and that's what we're looking as how we
can improve the outcomes for children
so it sounds like you're thinking about
permanent transformative
in your words change when is that review
going to
be announced when will we know what
you're going to do
well it's a whole series of different
changes the first step of those changes
is
what we announced just the other week uh
where we set out our plans for catch up
whether it's the expansion of uh
small groups
into helping children catch up what do
we know what's the time frame of it i
mean could it be in place for you
this summer holiday well uh what what
we've done is we've asked
sir kevin to look over a period of 18
months what we're going to be doing as a
department as a government
is looking at a whole series of options
and changes
but there are going to be you know it's
not just all going to be in one day when
it's all announced there's going to be a
whole series of actions that we are
going to undertake
to improve the life chances to improve
the education of children from the most
disadvantaged backgrounds
but actually all children how can we do
the absolute most for every single one
of them to ensure that they do
so much you know get the very best out
of themselves and get the very best out
of their education
okay um i want to talk now about exams
and you've obviously cancelled
exams as we know it for this year you
said that teachers
can effectively decide on the grades
that the people should get and
they can do this basically however they
want they can use many tests they can
look at old exams they can write their
own tests
they can be done under exam conditions
they can be done under zoom they can be
done at home or they can look at
coursework they can look at class work
i mean how on earth can you expect exam
results to be
fair and consistent in these conditions
sophie we are we'd always start off on
the basis of the best form of assessment
would be through examination of course
that's the most consistent way of being
able to assess
children uh but we won't we haven't been
in that position to be able to do that
this year so we've had to look at
alternative models this is why we've set
out a very clear structure
for teachers building scaffolding and
guidance around that so they understand
as to
what grades should be awarded for
individual pupils
making sure and the teachers i speak to
um you know
really are approaching this in the most
professional of manners and ways
recognizing how important it is using
that guidance but then on top of that
there's going to be a
both internal uh inspection and quality
assurance within
the school but additional to that is the
external
quality assurance that will be coming
from the exam boards uh this is in the
process of randomized
testing um you know in terms of uh
randomized orders of schools right
across the country to make sure they've
been following
uh the guidance and uh the the grades
so they've been awarding our
or results will they be looking at then
just to put it in context
well and on top of that if i can just
add uh on top of that
is where there are outliers where
schools are
sort of submitted grades that do not
seem to be consistent with what they've
always been able to achieve in the past
any of those outliers exam exam boards
were able to look at those incredibly
incredibly closely and actually work
with the schools to make sure there is
the right assessment
that's something that is going to be
going right across the country and there
is going to be
uh you know that large-scale randomized
sampling
but additional what is large scale what
is the
genuinely what is large-scale randomized
sampling how many samples are going to
look
at well we're going to be uh looking
extensively across
all school settings uh whether it's
private schools whether it's facebook
how many
and how many and and it will be many
many thousands that will be sort of
looked at in terms of part of that
process many many thousands of
schools or or grades or what across
schools exam centers okay because i mean
i guess
many would worry you're putting teachers
in a bit of an impossible position here
you've got
randomized exams you've got internal
assessments but many teachers will know
that there of course will be an
incentive to actually
inflate grades to er on the side of
generosity
and if they don't and their peers do in
other schools or in other classes
then they could be putting their pupils
at a disadvantage for life
well so sophie i i think that our whole
teaching profession approaches this
with the most serious sort of
professional approach
and what you would expect and what you
would want uh of teachers
and as teachers go into this process
they're going to be following the
guidelines very very closely
they're going to be looking at what the
exam boards have issued the
the grade descriptors of saying this is
what a
child is meant to have achieved if
they're to be given an a a b
or c at a level or a a 9876
um in gcse so they're going to be
looking at that exceptionally closely
there's a whole process of internal uh
quality assurance that has to go on
within the school
but on top of that that's not the uh
over
uh overlaying all that is that the
quality assurance is going to be there
by the examples looking at where there
is potential malpractice
and making sure they come down on that
and but you know
of course any form of assessment is
never going to be as good as
exams that's why we're so committed to
moving forward with exams if that'd be
possible but that's not going to be
feasible this year and
and actually if you've seen the response
uh you know whether we
the consultation we ran that was over a
hundred thousand
people took part in it and uh and a
response from those
teaching professional teaching
organizations they recognize that wow
this is a challenge for teachers
it is without a doubt the fairest and
the best approach that we can possibly
take in unusual circumstances
now i'm sure you'd admit it's been a
pretty difficult year
we've had the exam fiasco the algorithm
fiasco of last summer
children went back to school for one day
in january only to be sent
home again then of course according to
the education and
endowment foundation a decade of
progress closing that gap between
privileged pupils and more disadvantaged
potentially
lost do you think you've done a good job
well my focus sophie is always about
trying to deliver very best for children
whether that's for 1.7
billion pound catch-up money that we're
delivering into schools for
the launch of a tutoring program that
supports and targets for children from
the most disadvantaged backgrounds the
fact that we
launch a radical reform of post 16
education
making sure that children are best able
to
succeed in whatever route they go down
and my commitment my absolute commitment
by making sure that children are
back in school at the earliest
opportunity that's what my focus is and
making sure
that children are back in school on
monday
tomorrow and making sure they're in the
position to be able to
enjoy their education and really benefit
from it so that's my focus i'll
leave others to do the commentary okay
i'm just looking at the
cabinet approval ratings the latest
cabinet approval ratings is voted
for by conservative party members now
they're
pretty generous lot um liz trust is on
plus 86
richie sunak gone plus 74. pretty patel
who
broke the ministerial code is on plus
50. there's only two people in minus
territory there's amanda milling on
minus 4.5
and then there's you on minus 43.6
it's not great is it well sophie my my
focus
is on one thing getting our children
back into school tomorrow
making sure that children get the
benefit from education and
i think that's what people right across
the country want to
know that our focus the whole
government's focus is on in terms of
delivering
uh the education that we want all of our
children to benefit from so
you're very much talking about a you
know a westminster story
what i think our nation's parents and
our nation's children want to know
is that they're going back to school
tomorrow they're going to have a benefit
of a world-class education
that's what we're focused on delivering
on have you ever
wondered if you know part of the reason
that you're in the job still is because
you're really acting as a bit of a
firewall for boris johnson
you're soaking up a lot of flack from
the issues in education over the last
year
and protecting the prime minister well
the prime minister and myself
have a shared passion this uh belief
that we can transform education
transform the life chances
of everyone all the way through this
pandemic we have highlighted the
consistent fact that education is our
national priority
the schools would be the last things to
close and the
first things to open and that's what we
said and that's what we're actually
delivering on
so the prime minister myself have that
shared passion that shared commitment
for our schools uh and most importantly
for our children
that is where we're completely and
utterly united on
and you know as i say it's very much a
shared passion that's what we're
delivering on
that's why we've been putting the extra
investment in terms of catch up
helping children not just those children
from most disadvantaged backgrounds but
children from all backgrounds
best be able to get the best out of
their school life
okay and as you say the good news
certainly to see all those pupils return
to the classroom
from tomorrow gavin williamson thank you
very much for being on the program thank
you thanks for having me
education secretary gavin williamson
there well let's stick with that theme
of schools ahead of the big
return to the classroom tomorrow and
we're joined by the ofsted chief
inspector amanda spellman thank you very
much for being on the programme
um i just want to start with what you've
written in the sun on sunday today
and saying it's great the school gates
will be thrown open next week
but we know the school experience won't
be normal for some time yet
testing face masks do you think that
pupils and
parents are really ready for some of the
logistical challenges
i think the vast majority are they had a
bit of a taster of this last term
um i think what we can see about the
proportion of parents who are expecting
to have their children back in school
the first possible day
shows um that people can cope do you
think that children
are going to be prepared i guess for
wearing face masks not just in communal
areas like
corridors but all day in the classroom
children are adaptable and flexible and
i think the overwhelming
um thing we're seeing is that the vast
majority of parents the vast majority
of children vast majority of teachers
are really happy
to be going back to school i think they
can live with a little bit of
inconvenience for a few weeks
i really hope that the whole
paraphernalia of masks
and testing isn't only necessary for a
short time
i think we've got some reasons to be
optimistic from what we can see
but let's make sure that children get
the pleasure of learning the pleasure of
socializing
and the pleasure of all those wider
activities they get when they're at
school
i was talking to gavin williamson a bit
about what happens if children
just don't wear face masks and do you
think that they need to be
enforced in the classroom or do you
think that the current approach is the
right one
face masks testing this is part of a
system of infection control that's not
designed or expected to eliminate any
infection ever happening
it's designed to reduce it um to levels
that should that
shouldn't cause anybody anxiety um so
of course they're always going to be a
small proportion of children and of
adults who can't wear face masks
um but we shouldn't we shouldn't let
anxieties about a tiny proportion
stop us recognizing um the overall goal
here
it was interesting as well to hear you
talk about how you hope that this will
be for a limited amount of time
what kind of period are you hoping that
it will last for before
some of these measures can be eased well
i think we've been told that
the face mask guidance will be reviewed
at easter i think so
i i love the idea of children being able
to come back in the summer term able
able to see everybody fully
okay now often of course began
inspecting schools again in january
checks had previously been
suspended because of covid what kind of
things
are your inspections finding well we've
reported through the autumn we did
interim visits that weren't judgment
visits and we're doing monitoring visits
now
what we've seen this term has shown the
extraordinary efforts that schools have
been putting into remote education it's
been
very hard work for teachers and of
course as we know not as
nothing like as rewarding on the
receiving end so it's one of the reasons
why we should all be very happy about
getting back to school but schools have
been thinking about
what it is is the is the the minimum
curriculum they want to make sure that
children get even when they're working
remotely
a lot of effort has gone into making
sure that almost all children
are able to to reach the curriculum
through through one kind of device or
another
um but it has been a slog it's been a
real slog
people are children at the receiving end
are bored lonely miserable
anxious and really really want the
normal experience again
yeah you can definitely see slog is
probably the right word there
how worried are you about the mental
health aspect of this as well you know
we talk an awful lot about
academic achievement about exams about
catch-up and progress but
it does strike me that you know it's
been very hard for
young people mentally from a mental
health perspective
and all this time at home cut off from
their friends staring at the computer
it has been very hard and i just said
that lonely bored miserable um that's
very very common but i think the good
news is that for the vast majority of
children
the restoration of normality um everyday
experience of
the sense of learning being with friends
being with teachers
um getting getting to play football or
whatever it might happen to be again
that of itself for most children will be
enough
to lift those symptoms to get to to get
them back into into
into being the children um they were
before and will be again
but there is a there is a minority um
let's hope it's not too large a minority
who whose problems have increased and
it's really important that that
we we're good at recognizing um where
problems are arising things like eating
disorders things like self-harm
i know um that mental health services
are very aware
of the the kinds of problems that have
been increasing and where they can
expect
more more cases coming through so
everybody needs to be alert to these
the education secretary and gavin
williamson was pretty clear
that changes to the school holidays are
on the table
that they could be looking at a
five-term year potentially or shortening
the summer holiday that's one of the
things
that this review is looking into you've
written today saying making school days
longer or school holidays shorter could
backfire
why do you think it could backfire well
first of all i really want to make sure
that all children
do get their their full full ration of
schooling and we don't want children to
lose out in the long term they're
they've been postponed to the interests
of the old and the sick while we've
dealt with coronavirus but
but children really matter and their
lives matter
um in terms of adjustments to to school
days and school years
many experiments have happened in the
past um i think one of the really
important things is to learn from the
experiments that have happened in the
past because
of course there's no put there's no
point adding time here or
moving time there if you get if if you
don't get a groundswell of support if
children simply don't turn up
for extra time or summer schools for
example you could end up putting a lot
of effort
into something that doesn't achieve the
objective so my concern is to make sure
that we go with the grain
of what parent parents will embrace um
to make sure that all children get the
very most out of their education
you talk about what experiments have
shown previously
and what have they shown with with
regards to holidays
i think a number of schools have
experimented over the last couple of
decades with things like five term years
i don't think many of those have
persisted i don't know the reasons why
um but but i think it's really important
to to learn
if people and if people are proposing um
to redesign to make sure that people
understand
um why they haven't been a long-standing
success in the past and
make sure they're designed in ways that
people really will throw themselves into
supporting
okay and on social media quite a few
people have contacted me with very
different experiences of home schooling
and
of the kind of lessons that their
classes are providing of the sort of
teacher support that they're giving
obviously this is anecdotal but what has
your inspection shown
in terms of whether or not there is
consistency
about the amount of support schools have
provided over
over lockdown last summer when there
weren't explicit requirements for
schools it was clear that there was
enormous variability um in the
experience that children were getting i
think what our monitoring visits
this term have shown um is that is is
that we're getting much
closer um to um consistency and in that
there are there are clear minimum
expectations of some quite significant
input and that the vast majority
of schools schools are putting that
effort in and the vast majority of
children
are receiving that having said which
there will always be corners
um whether whether whether problems i'm
not saying that every child in the
country
um has had the full experience they
should but but compared with last year
um it's a very very much better picture
but it is still tiring exhausting
draining for everybody
um i think if there's one thing we've
learned it's quite how important
schools actual schools physical schools
are for adults and for children
yeah i think that's certainly something
that parents and pupils wouldn't
disagree with you with and just finally
i know this isn't strictly your brief
but i just want to get your thoughts on
exams and do you think that having
teachers effectively deciding
exam results is the right way to go
there is no perfect solution this year
we have a system that's designed for
normal years when
all children have had more or less the
same access um to education
this year for obvious reasons it's been
very unequal
across across the country between
schools so there was a groundswell
of opinion that said that said it
wouldn't be fair simply to run exams as
normal
um because the results would recognize
that in would be as much about that
inequality and access as they would
about
um how well children have done and with
what they have been taught or what
potential they've got for progression
so we've got a hybrid here um which is i
think i think is it is a a good attempt
at creating um the best we can do in
in very very unsatisfactory
circumstances
i think what what we need to do is have
everybody embrace it and do as much as
we can to make it work
okay amanda spun thank you so much for
being on the program this morning thank
you
thank you
now tomorrow marks international women's
day coronavirus have of course affected
everyone in so many ways but there have
been some issues
that have hit women particularly hard
whether it's on child care job prospects
or domestic abuse
yesterday i spoke to the executive
director of un women fumes elaine
mumbello
and i asked her whether things have
improved or got worse for women around
the world in the last year
well we unfortunately have been
hard hit by the pandemic and some of the
gains that we made
in the last two decades especially
are under significant threats
during the pandemic women have lost most
of the jobs about two-thirds of the jobs
that were lost
there were jobs that belongs to women
and this is because women tend to be at
the lower end
with jobs that are not protected with
jobs that have
do not have enforceable contracts and in
some countries are not even covered by
the labor laws
so it's very easy to get rid of women in
times of crisis
we've seen girls dropping out of school
in larger numbers
again this is one area where we've been
making progress in the last
two decades but also women's leadership
is not being taken as seriously as we
need
to be taking it serious and we've seen
now
even during this crisis that in the task
teams and committees
that are dealing with covet women are
underrepresented
in 87 countries that we service only
about 3.6
have gender equal
you know a representation of men and
women and you can't have men
fixing the issues that affect women most
it's interesting you're talking
about women in leadership throughout the
pandemic because in countries where
we've had women leaders there's actually
been quite a lot of praise for how
they've dealt with it in places like new
zealand and germany for instance
absolutely and this year's theme for
international women's day is on israel
women's leadership
there is an opportunity here at the back
of this pandemic
to actually promote women's leadership
and we have this evidence of women who
have performed
very well and have managed
the pandemic in in an impressive way
you talked about women in the workplace
and the impact it's had and
of course in the uk it's also had you
know a big
big impact on how women are doing in the
workplace the pandemic so for example
you know 17 mothers in the uk so they've
had to
give up on work during the pandemic
mothers on the lowest incomes nine times
more likely
to have lost their jobs and do you worry
that even in
places like the uk and wealthy nations
that the pandemic could set back
women's progress potentially decades oh
absolutely
i mean just for women sleeping out of
the labor market
is a is a big issue and in countries
like
the uk where women did uh achieve
much better representation in the labor
market
it is going to cost us a
a lot to have those those women now not
spending
and not being able to be as independent
as they were
as a as working mothers working women
another aspect that we've seen in the uk
is in domestic violence
the number of people reporting uh
domestic violence the un's described it
as a shadow pandemic how concerned are
you that as we're told to stay at home
it's actually not a safe place for so
many women we have
caught this interest
of gender-based violence a
pandemic of its own a shadow pandemic
that has existed before there was a
covert 19 and will continue to exist
after private 19. so we need
to fight it not just for what is
happening now during the pending but
fight it for the future as well
and deal with it as a pandemic with all
hands on deck
in the context of gender-based violence
our frontline workers are social workers
the police civil society
the judiciary all of those we need to
make decisions that
will prevent the violence from happening
as well as they prosecute
in some countries the increase has been
as high
as 40 percent i'm also interested as
well if you're worried about
uh increased nationalism the country is
effectively looking to
protect themselves because they're
dealing with the crisis
of kobit rather than reaching out and
trying to help
people in other countries so in the uk
for example you know we've reduced the
aid budget from 0.7 to 0.5
of gdp we've cut aid to yemen
how much of a concern is this for the un
it really is concerning us
and we are appealing for countries to be
generous at this time of need a
solidarity in a time like this is
actually important
because in in the fight against the
pandemic
a safety in one country
when there is no safety in another
country is not real safety
we need to fight the pandemic all over
the world and to help each other
because we will not be able to be safer
if one part of the world is not safe
the same thing about driving countries
into extreme poverty we know that when
people are desperate
they will move around the world so the
people that you are
living exposed to extreme poverty will
show up
on your desktop at some point so we have
to be
a in this all together we are also
concerned about women who are refugees
and migrants and
in people who are refugees and migrants
because
covert has tended to push people out of
countries that are hosting them back to
their own countries where sometimes they
do not have the infrastructure
to survive in their own countries
because they already migrated
to a new country and sometimes they
don't have the papers to be moving back
and forth so migrants are finding
themselves in very difficult situations
we're also concerned about equitable
distribution
of vaccine because there is a danger
also that women
in some situations will not be given
first preference
for accessing the vaccine if we know
about the preference for for boys the
preference
for men men could easily be in front of
of the line claiming that they are the
ones who are
maybe going out to work confining women
in the home space
which comes with its own complications
so we want governments to pay attention
to executable
distribution of the vaccine and make
sure that women
are not discriminated against just
finally
when i was researching you at the
interview i was just very struck by your
own
sort of background growing up in south
africa a teacher
becoming south africa's first female
deputy president at president
also having five children it's a pretty
impressive cv
and what is it about your own experience
uh
growing up and becoming a a woman that
really sort of drove you and listened to
bargy
you know i grew up in in south africa at
a time
of apartheid so
you were thrust into activism because of
the situation
of the country i also had a mother
who was an activist in her own right so
there was a push from the home front but
also
as a student by
friends and fellow students where
activists in the main and in fact
for people of my age group if you are
not
an activist you really
were somehow on the wrong track
because everything pointed you in a
direction
that's called on you to take action
about what was happening
in the country it was much easier to be
an activist than to fold your heads
that's very interesting and thank you so
much for being on the program
today and talking a bit about
international women's day we appreciate
it
thank you
the executive director of un women there
head of international women's day well
we're going to talk about that with our
next guest but there's a lot of other
things to discuss
too the shadow foreign secretary lisa
nandy joins us now from wigan thank you
so much for being
on the program this morning um i just
want to start with
the budget and one of the most
significant things to come out the
budget was this freeze and income tax
levels
now i was kind of under the impression
that labour supported that by reading
the observer
that you're going to vote against it can
you clear up what is labour's position
we are going to vote against it this
week we think that now is absolutely the
wrong time
to be targeting low and middle-income
earning families
for tax hikes and squeezing their
incomes not least because
if you do that it means that they're not
going out and spending on the high
streets and the economy
the recovery is very fragile at the
moment we were really concerned when
those plans
were announced that what the government
was effectively saying was that low and
middle-income earning families would be
targeted
to start paying into the system a full
year before
many of those major corporations because
the corporation tax rise doesn't come in
until a year later the shadow chancellor
pushed the chancellor on that
um at the dispatch box we couldn't get a
satisfactory answer we think this is the
wrong thing to do so we'll be voting
against it this week
you said that shadow chancellor pushed
um
on this but at the same time it does
feel like it's been a bit of a change of
heart and you didn't oppose that earlier
in the week
and the shadow chancellor told my
colleague caitlin cannon wednesday
it would have been the wrong decision to
do it now but more sensible to take
these measures in the future
i mean it is a year in the future it
feels like there's been a change of
policy here
is that a bit opportunistic
no we've been we've been absolutely
consistent about this that we don't want
to see low
and middle income earning families
paying the price for this pandemic but
just to come in here
just just sorry just to come in if i may
because you you've made the point on
lower and middle income and a few times
and
yes i i accept that it will impact them
but it does
affect higher rate taxpayers more
doesn't it
it's not targeted it does but it it it
does but we've been consistent in saying
that the recovery
is very fragile there are businesses in
this country including many in my
constituency here in wigan that just
haven't had
they haven't been open for most of the
last year because we've been in almost
permanent
lockdown in parts of the north of
england and
what they most need to see is families
going out and spending again when
um when we start to unlock they're
looking forward to that they think they
can survive if we do that
but if you start to target those
families too quickly what you'll see
then
is the recovery choked off before it's
even begun
we're also very concerned about the fact
that buried in the small print of this
budget
was a council tax rise for those
families we're going to see cuts to
universal credit coming in
in six months what you're what you're
hitting families with
is a perfect storm where their incomes
are going to be
squeezed from multiple directions and we
just think that that is the wrong thing
to do it's the wrong thing to do for
those families but it's also the wrong
thing to do for the economy
just wonder if it sounds to some like a
bit of a cake and eat it approach
um you're voting against tax risers you
want to see
more public spending on things like
nurses pay for example
because you're also of course saying
that the government's planned one
percent payrolls for nurses isn't enough
what do you want to see well
i don't think this is a heavy cake and
eat it approach i think this is entirely
in step
with most major economies if you look
over at the united states
joe biden is putting in a fiscal
stimulus package worth trillions the
european union
is following suits i think there is a an
economic consensus
that the way in which we're going to get
through this
is to make sure that we protect
businesses and workers
right now and actually the you know
there was an argument about that in the
conservative party but ultimately that
is an argument that the chancellor
accepted by delaying
corporation tax rises in this budget we
want to see
money going into the pockets of low
earners hard working
low earners including lower middle
earners in the national health service
who deserve it who've got us through
this crisis
who've gone out and worked every single
day were promised a pay rise
and should get at the very least what
they were promised
and that is the way that you get the
economy moving again we saw that in 2010
when we had a
huge deep cuts to the public sector it
took money out of the pockets of working
people and it choked off
any prospect of recovery in towns like
mine we cannot afford to keep making
these mistakes again
the question was about nurses pay the
you say that the government's plan one
percent pay rise isn't enough
what pay rise do you want to see well
the government
to be clear is not planning a pay raise
the buried in the small print of this
budget was not only that
uh that what do you want to see i'm just
trying to work out
but i'm trying to work out what what's
labour calling for
yeah i'm just making the point that that
is a real terms pay cut because it
doesn't keep
pace with inflation and for nurses to be
offered a pay cut
is just reprehensible in our view the
in the nhs long-term plan the government
budgeted for a 2.1
pay rise that is what nurses were
promised and last year they
legislated for that in order to give
nurses a cast iron guarantee
that after years and years of seeing
their real terms pay
full that the government would finally
reverse that situation and start to see
their pay increase we think they ought
to go into these negotiations
at a bare minimum honoring that promise
of 2.1
and then considering what more they can
offer
to our nhs staff who have done so much
to put their families and themselves at
risk every day going into work some of
them have died
what can they offer to our nhs workforce
who've done so much
for them so what are you calling above
that 2.1 what do you
think at the very minimum yeah we think
at the very minimum they
they must honor that commitment that
they wrote into law at 2.1
and then there is a process ongoing
where a pay review body
rightly looks at this independently of
government they will make
recommendations to government
but we think nurses deserve a pay rise
this year and that should never have
been something that was up for
negotiation this is a government that
has completely got its priorities wrong
if they can give a special advisor who
broke the rules of 50
pay rise but then offer our nurses a
real terms pay cut
that is a government that just has not
understood who it is that is getting us
through this crisis
and who deserves to be fairly rewarded
the royal college of nursing says it's
preparing for
possible strike action would you support
nurses
striking well i'll always support
nurses i've always supported nhs staff
since i was elected
11 years ago but nurses in my
constituency who i met last week are not
asking me
for a strike they weren't promised a
strike they were promised a pay rise
and that is what i'm determined that
they're going to get a pay rise
and the resources for the national
health service that last year the
chancellor said would absolutely
categorically
be delivered he will he said we will
give the nhs
whatever it takes and instead buried in
the small print of this budget
was an 8 billion pound cut for the nhs
they were promised a pay rise
they were promised resources for the
national health service and that is why
i'm determined to stand shoulder to
shoulder with
our nursing staff in order to make sure
that the government delivers
okay now children of course returning to
the classroom
tomorrow big news for pupils teachers
and parents of course
um in secondary schools teachers and
pupils are going to be told that they
should wear face masks unless they're
exempt
it's non-binding guidance though does
labour think it should be a legal
obligation i think all the way through
this health crisis when we've met with
sage scientists and had regular
briefings they've been absolutely
clear that you can't enforce public
health you have to carry people
with you and i think going down a route
of enforcing
compelling students to to take actions
is probably not the right approach it's
not the right approach for students for
parents
and many teachers in my constituents
have been telling me that they feel that
that would be
unenforceable i think what we really
need to see is a wider
plan of action to help people comply
with the measures
on testing for example there are a
number of parents who are very worried
about their children
being tested one of the reasons for that
is because many parents can't afford to
self-isolate at the moment if their
child's test
comes back positive so we've been
pushing the government to extend the
self-isolation payments 70
of people who apply for it are rejected
and that's why
one of the reasons why only three in 10
people are actually doing it so
i think there are other measures that we
could take rather than trying to force
teachers to go around policing math
squaring and other measures in schools
that would actually be far more
effective
um now i'm keen to ask about nazanin
zagari ratcliffe as well the british
mother
in jail in iran now her sentence is due
to come to an end
today but her husband richard basically
said he doesn't know what's going to
happen
do you have any intelligence on on what
is likely had to happen to nazaneen and
what should be done
i don't it's been frustratingly slow in
relation to progress
on this issue and when i met with
richard ratcliffe
recently it was clear how difficult this
process has been
the family are very keen to to continue
to have the support of the foreign
office but
i think i i can say frankly that there
just hasn't been enough focus
and enough effort not just on nazanin's
case which is heartbreaking
but also on the other british dual
iranian nationals who are
currently being held in iran
we need to see much more progress on
this i you know when i meet this family
i just feel that there's
there's not much more that they can take
of this to be honest and other countries
have made more progress
in getting their nationals home we need
to see a really concerted effort now
across government led by the prime
minister uh to make up
for some of the mistakes that he's made
in the past and to make sure that we get
nazanin home and other dual nationals
home as well
okay now of course it's international
women's day tomorrow
and it does feel if if you look at the
data that the pandemic has had a
disproportionate impact
on women particularly mothers 17 of
mothers have had to give up on work
during the pandemic
72 percent cut that hours mothers on the
lowest incomes
nine times more at risk of losing their
jobs
are you worried that the pandemic could
set back women's progress
in the workplace potentially by years
decades
i i am worried about it one of the
things that we've seen
um over the course of this pandemic is a
rise in working from home that's
obviously
had a huge effect on people's ability to
deal with
caring responsibilities not just child
care but care for elderly parents
as well but there is a gap between the
numbers of women who intend to return
full-time to the workplace if they get
the choice
and the numbers of men who do and there
is a concern that that could continue to
widen those inequalities you know the
people who are in the workplace
far more visible far more likely to be
making decisions far more likely to be
promoted so i think there's a risk that
as we come out of this we could see
those inequalities that have widened
already during the pandemic widen
even further i'm particularly concerned
that
women lack an obvious champion within
government
and that these issues that often end up
being invisible as a consequence
i was listening to your last interview
with real interest
it's fairly obvious that the more women
you have at the highest levels
making these decisions the less likely
it is that women
become an afterthought in decisions that
are made
so i think this is something that the
government absolutely does need to take
seriously and start to address
talking about having women in leadership
roles it's 2021
labour still hasn't had a female leader
i know you round yourself but not only
that but when labour did try
you did try to be fair but when labour
members have gone to vote
in the ballot for their preferred
candidate a woman hasn't even placed
above a man i mean that's pretty
depressing isn't it
i think it is frustrating for labour and
i won't dress that up i found it
particularly frustrating in the
leadership contest to hear
you know some of the things that women
often hear in when they're putting
themselves forward for leadership
positions you haven't got the experience
it's not your turn they were you know
you don't look like a prime minister
i wasn't the only person to hear those i
think becky long bailey
heard quite a bit bit of that and so did
the other other candidates who weren't
men that is really frustrating that's
something that i'm absolutely committed
that we're going to start to turn around
and change but i have to say that
you know since that leadership contest
working with kyocera and angela rayner
i know that's something they're
absolutely committed to we've got our
first ever
shadow female chancellor of the
exchequer i'm the first
um famed woman to ever hold the post
of shadow foreign secretary you know if
you look at labour's top team we've got
women in those
key positions and i just hope that by
being in those positions
and by standing up and providing a
strong challenge to the government and
an alternative
about how to bring britain forwards that
we are showing the way
that women can be in those leadership
roles and that you know ultimately that
that will change and that we will have a
female leader at some point
in the future not yet i should hasten to
add
but i'm not going to do that again just
as something
just just to clarify um but
they you know that it is important
actually that women are in those roles
when i was growing up
there were women in leadership roles
people like tessa jowl who went on to
become
a mentor of mine i cannot tell you how
much those women
matter in those leadership roles you
know people like diane abbott as well
really strong women who broke the mold
and and
and blazed a trail it really matters and
i'm absolutely determined that our
generation is not going to drop the ball
on this that we're going to keep seeing
progress
i remember during that labour leadership
contest uh you said at one point that
you'd quite like to see queen megan
i just wonder how you're feeling about
the cup some of the coverage
of meghan markle and prince harry you're
going to be watching the oprah winfrey
interview i feel like i absolutely
jinxed that i
should probably never have said it
because things have only got worse for
the royal family since
then and i have to say that i you know
my heart does go out to everybody
involved in this it's
difficult being in the public eye it's
particularly difficult when your family
is dragged into this and what i see when
i look at the royal family as a family
going through a very difficult time
all of it being played out in public
with maximum
publicity i think it would be far better
for them if they were able to
to deal with this privately behind the
scenes and and to be honest i think it
would be better for the country as well
they're having a very hard time but so
are hundreds of thousands of families
in this country at the moment because of
covid i think that they're the families
that we ought to be focusing on
okay lisa and andy thank you so much for
being on the program thank you
thank you now
it's been a very busy week but few
stories were more significant than
nicolas sturgeon giving evidence to the
inquiry
it's investigating the scottish
government's handling of sexual
harassment allegations against former
first minister
alex salmond the government was found to
have acted unlawfully
mr salmond was cleared of the charges in
court nicholas sturgeon avoided any
major damage in her marathon
evidence session on wednesday but she is
still under pressure with critics
alleging she broke the ministerial code
now that could be a resigning matter and
a new poll for the scotland on sunday
newspaper today
the first since the first minister's
appearance before the inquiry suggests
the row could be hurting
the scottish independent movement now
the polls found that support for
independence has dropped
to 48 with 52 now saying they would vote
no in the second referendum and of
course the summit inquires the first
the main issue driving support for at
the union with more than a third of
people citing it
as their primary reason 43 of people so
they trust
nicola sturgeon less now due to the
inquiry
26 so they trust her more 25 say their
view is unchanged
and meanwhile 46 of respondents say they
trust the scottish government less
due to that inquiry well let's talk more
about this we're joined by the snp's
murray black thank you
very much for being uh with us um we've
just seen the details of that new
the first poll since nicola sturgeon's
evidence
are you concerned that this is now
starting to damage support for
independence
well i mean i think that that's been in
the back of the minds of
any snp supporter for a long time now
and but i think the the important point
is that
these polls just give a snapshot and
this particular poll isn't comparable to
previous polls so i would take it with a
a pinch of caution but
ultimately it goes to show that we
cannot take anything for granted you
know and one of the things that i
actually have always liked about the snp
is that
we've been very upfront in saying that
it is on us
to convince people of the case for
independence so it just shows that
we still have work to do and i'll take
your point that i think it's right that
hasn't been waited for
um turnout for example this poll so not
necessarily directly
uh comparable um but you do acknowledge
that
there are concerns within the snp that
what we've seen play out between nicola
sturgeon and alex salmond could have
damaged that support
well i think that the
conflict within any political party is
can often lead to damaging
certainly damaging the reputation and
the the look of the party but
i i don't think that that's necessarily
what is happening just now
um and it touches more broadly on
this harassment inquiry in general and i
think
a lot of people are almost trying to to
force agendas onto these issues
and the real issue at the heart of all
of these
the things that we're talking about is
the women
that you know were complaining the
complainants
and ultimately as politicians i think we
have to ask ourselves
that throughout this saga have we made
it
easier or more difficult for people to
come forward
and and i think that's what the focus
should be
rather than you know internal party
politics as such
and what do you think the answer to that
question is to the
the question of whether it's easier for
women to come forward
oh i i i wouldn't say so no i think
that's
the the way that this inquiry has has
played out
has just been horrendous and i i can't
imagine
the the horror of the the experience
that
the complainants are having just now um
and there's a couple of things to to
make clear that the first thing is
the scottish government did make a
mistake in terms of
how they actually implemented this
policy and it's actually quite
refreshing i think
to see the first minister in particular
put our hands up and sincerely say yeah
no
we could do better and that's what the
point of this inquiry should be
is to figure out how can we make sure
that this kind of mistake never happens
again
and instead what we've had is just this
barrage of
conspiracy theories of um attacks on our
institutions of
clear political agendas uh taking
precedence
over what is a very serious issue
okay i mean you say that the scottish
government has admitted
mistakes that it's refreshing that
nicola sturgeon has held her hands up
but no one's resigned have they is that
really taking responsibility
yeah i appreciate your point um and in
terms of
resignations and things i think it's
important to remember
that the the the committee inquiry has
still to be published
so you know i think it would be a bit
presumptuous to to start a you know
sacking people right now
but you've just had the government let
people down though
the right thing to do to take
responsibility yes but i
think that it's important that we figure
out where that responsibility actually
lies
and in terms of the implication that
this somehow lies with the first
minister
i would say that's where we've we know
that there is a current
inquiry being undertaken by james
hamilton which
the fm actually referred herself to
for further scrutiny on top of the the
a committee inquiry so i i just i
can't help but notice the double
standards as well here because
you know when we talk about these issues
we've heard
the scottish conservatives in particular
and for instance they put out a press
release
before the first minister had even given
evidence
to the committee calling for her to
resign
and that's just ludicrous and shows
what the real agenda is there but in
comparison
a court has shown that boris johnson has
misled parliament
and yet i'm not seeing any eight hours
questioning sessions
for him or seeing him submit himself to
the kind of scrutiny that the fm
is it's not about boris johnson though
is it what we're talking about here
specifically is what is happening
in scotland we're talking about nicola
sturgeon as well and
just looking at the ministerial code
it's quite clear the scottish
government's ministerial code says legal
advice
should be considered at the earliest
opportunity now on the 31st of october
2018
the government's own lawyer said its
argument in the case against alex
salmond was more likely to fail
than succeed on the 6th of december they
said that the least worst option was to
concede the case
so why did it take until 8th of january
the following year for that to happen
well i mean there's again a few
different things
to consider here the what has been
published so far what the fm made clear
was that there are continually different
legal opinions throughout a process and
what the government were advised
as that we are now starting to see cause
for concern
in our case however we think that the
legal grounds
themselves are sufficient enough to keep
pushing
this so it kind of comes down to in my
view
the semantics and the details of the
actual
the institutions and the you know the
law themselves
and so i think it's important to let due
process uh take its place so
but the the fm has been very clear that
the moment
that it was made clear to her that the
case
had there was no point and pursuing it
sorry how can you say that though that
the moment she thought that
the case wasn't going to be there when
on the 31st of october the government's
own lawyers said the case was more
likely to fail than
of december the least worst option was
to concede the case and yet you didn't
do anything to the 8th of january i mean
it doesn't really sound that way does it
well no
there's also a couple of things to
consider because
legal advice is made up of different
sources so there's a lot of different
things
to consider and the october the letter
that you're referencing
my understanding is that there was still
grounds
for it to be pursued in court because
the distinction that i think was
important that the fm made
is that where the flaw was in this
process
was in how we implemented the policy the
actual policy itself
remains intact it remains in effect and
currently untested and so it
i know it's a slight point but i think
it's an important one
so the ministerial code may have been
broken according to
critics the government has acknowledged
it acted unlawfully
you yourself say that the complainants
have been let down
over half a million pounds of taxpayers
money's been lost
at some point does someone need to
resign for this
again i think it's important that we let
inquiries take the
process i do i think it would be
inappropriate for me to
you know be making assumptions on that
that we have these but
these things aren't assumptions i'm
talking about things that have happened
in what sense the the we don't know that
actually
has been very clear women have been let
down as you said
yes no the fact that women have been let
down completely and i think that
that's again my first point is where
the committee inquiry i think its focus
should be looking at
right what is it that went wrong and my
understanding is that it was
uh to do with prior communication
with complainants that that was the
issue around the
the actual implementation of the policy
but like i say are we making it easier
or more difficult for people to come
forward and i think when you
consider how the the
women at the heart of this have actually
been weaponized for different narratives
that has been the most upsetting thing
for me uh
to see and of course the government
should face scrutiny and
i don't see any evidence to suggest that
the government are trying to evade
that scrutiny but i think it's important
to let processes play out
the government should face scrutiny but
should the government also be held
accountable
of course someone need to take
responsibility and lose their job
well of course but you're asking me
should someone lose their job
over something that we don't know the
complaint no but i'm asking you whether
they should
should with respect to whether they
should lose their job over things that
we do know
the government's acted unlawfully right
women
have been let down half a million pounds
worth of taxpayers money lost
these are things that we know not
completely i understand that but
who is it in particular that you're
thinking we should
that you're asking me whether they
should resign well either the first
minister or so who else
you think that was responsible for the
mistakes that the government made
well like i say that these reviews are
currently in
motion just now to identify where what
went wrong and where it went wrong
and actually one of the things that has
hampered that process
is constantly having to rebut the
wild conspiracy theories that have been
touted by some
okay now tomorrow is international
women's day uh
important day of course and women have
been hit particularly hard by
the pandemic scotland but across the uk
and also across the world as well and
whether you look at things like domestic
abuse
childbirth women in the workplace are
you worried about the impact that the
pandemic's had on women's rights
yes the impact that the pandemic has had
on women in general
you know sadly the the trend in most
areas of politics seems to be that
issues
predominantly affect women much worse
than they do others
and the fact that we know as you alluded
to earlier on in the program you know
that
single parents in particular have been
really struggling during this period
it's it hasn't undoubtedly been tough
yeah i think certainly lots of people
would agree with that um you've
previously of course
um criticized westminster for being a
bit of a boys club and for
being a sexist institution what has your
experience been
uh exactly that to be honest with you
um it's i think
westminster in particular it does i
think the people within it
often have a view that is some kind of
private membership club
and and it's very bizarre
at times um in the manner in which i
think
people conduct themselves often is
very macho if not outright misogynistic
at times
and so yeah i've certainly experienced
that but on the other hand
i have experienced the
uh an attempt to raise awareness about
these issues in an attempt by
parliament to address some of these
issues and so i do have to give credit
where it's true
at least they're trying yeah definitely
still worth trying i mean you're saying
that you've
sort of experienced or seen things that
are misogynistic what kind of things are
you
talking about um well the one that
always springs to mind was
the the first time that i was elected
i was sitting out in the terrace and
there was a
uh elder member i will say
uh who sat down with me and i remember
asking
what when is again the summer
holidays are and they leaned in and said
i think you'll find
it's called recess darling and i had to
reply i think you'll find i'm called
marry
sweetheart and so you know just
daft things like that happen
much more often than they should um and
that begins to seep out into
the narrative and how we talk about
other issues and i think
that particularly when it comes to
poverty and the pandemic
we are seeing that a lot of people in
government and
in parliament general don't quite get it
they're not seeing
how as impacting women
disproportionately and
why that matters and why we have to do
something to address that
yeah certainly something worth
highlighting ahead of uh international
women's day thank you so much for being
on the programme
at murray black there thank you
well that is it for the main show don't
go anywhere though in just a moment
we'll be reviewing everything we've just
heard
in sophie ridge the take and if you want
even more analysis
you can check out the sophie ridge on
sunday podcast that's available from
lunchtime
in all the usual places stay where you
are because
i'm gonna be back after this short break
you